because I mean if it is true that if I'm
living the way I'm living I'm gonna go
to hell I don't want that they live and
die
yeah so I would say would that be
insulted anyone what's the difference
between us and a me and a cow the cow
the cow lives and is more intelligent
no I think I am so here bossy in a cow
eats dream sleeps replicates and lives
his life I can't be like you want more
intelligent I can't be like ok but here
it's not just dreams need replicate
outcomes we're more important than ever
to like all good ok let me tell you
something yep it is time we have kind of
a concept there we have the Angels we
believe in angels the Angels do as
they're told
God says you do this they do as they're
told they're then we have the animals
and then we have human beings in the
chain yeah the angels do as they're told
the animals Apple instant yeah what
makes us better than angels or lower
than animals is the following either
either we become better than the Angels
why because the Angels don't have a free
will we do so if I choose to obey God
and try to follow his Commandments
yeah then that makes me better than the
Angels because I'm doing it because I
want to the Angels do it because they
have to know what would make me worse
than the animals is that I would say no
whatever I want to do I'm gonna do it I
don't care what it is I don't question
it etc so now I'm not I'm not saying
anyone's an animal should I give an
understanding that we as human beings we
have a purpose were intelligent the way
we design my fingerprint doesn't match
anybody else's fingerprint
yet to wave my body works if I have a
cop look I had a cut there the way it
builds itself the DNA the DNA is a
factory yeah so hold on a second all of
these stuff old systems older old
factory we look at a robot hand robotic
Hannah would say Wow the man who made
that must be so intelligent we glorify
you we praise him but the man who made
the airplane thank you
I don't need to travel to Saudi Arabia
in four months I can get there in six
hours
thank you very much so what about the
one who created the man who made the
plane
the purpose in life is that we find huge
freedom in having that connection and
relationship with God Almighty and
understanding our true purpose which is
to the Quran because I mean if it is
true that if I'm living the way I'm
living I'm gonna go to hell I don't want
I want to see you're gonna go help what
it is in Islam and all religions have
this concept of you don't believe in our
religion you're going home
Allah says in the Quran we do not punish
a nation until we send the messenger so
if you haven't heard the message of
Islam we have three categories for
custom reason a person who hasn't
reached age of unity somebody who's not
mentally stable and somebody who hasn't
heard the message of Islam if you die in
that state but you never heard this lamb
but we'll test you under their judgement
specific tests however if you know it's
time to be the truth and you reject it
then you're in trouble which is before
neurosurgery for wouldn't reject him
that's the did you see what you said and
this is sincerity this is submitting
your will that's saying you know what
because there's people at the time of
the Prophet when he came with a
revelation there were the Arabs they
knew him to be the chief oh they knew
that he was a truthful man he this is
why I said to them listen to the scene
he went to them and said because he was
claiming is a prophet here where the
miracles inside the fire and war will
thank reject this is what I'm saying
this is so key he went to them and said
the following here he stood on the
mountain and he said if I told you guys
behind this mountain is an army coming
to destroy us would you believe me they
said of course we believe you we know
you to be the truthful we've never heard
you like because I'm telling you I'm the
Messenger of God they go we don't want
to know this is what you call this is
why God says in the Quran that every
stubborn is because I enjoy yes because
you know what it is they saying this is
the way I know I don't care so the first
we will show the miracles of a miracle
which is miracles know why because in a
desire you know this why Allah says
have you seen the one who takes his
desire as his good meaning this comes
first what I want comes first and Islam
is about submission once you acknowledge
there's got there and you want a
relation with him you submit God I
submit to you whatever needs to be done
you know and that's what it is and this
is like you said beautifully yet how
could you not believe if it's the truth
sadly there are people there in those
times who even today we show them
evidence they don't want to know
nope I don't care I said would you want
how can i pretty good if God came he
said I am good who says I'm not maybe
it's illusion what can we do our job is
to convey our countries nobody's heart I
can pray for you you can pray for me I
don't know what I'm gonna end up today
I'm talking about this I don't know
where I'm gonna end up so I could I
don't never look down on anyone in Bihar
this guy certified - yeah so it's got
all hamdu lillahi rabbil alameen
arrahmani arraheem manly Chioma Dean
I'll translate
yeah can a buddha wa iyyaka nastain bina
sirat al-mustaqim sirata al-ladhina and
I'm telling him guy real must obey
alayhi wa la darling this is something
that you must have it's a pillow so what
that means is it says mr. merriman I'm
in the name of Allah the most merciful
the very merciful ya
hamdulillah here a banana me or praises
belong to the one who's the master of
the whole universe yeah al-hamdu lillahi
rabbil alameen or praises to the one he
was created the whole universe yet
rabbul aalameen i rahmani raheem
the most merciful the very merciful and
I'm glad name's Malik Malik iam edenia
owner of the Day of Judgment ya can a
buddha wa iyyaka nastain
you alone we worship you alone we ask
for help yeah Tina Surratt almost no
sorry
yeah can a Buddha why can a stained
sirata al-ladhina an AMTA alayhim ghayri
must obey allah wa la darlene
guidance to the path guide us to the
straight path of those of whom your
favorites not of those who have earned
and gone and gone astray yet so here we
acknowledge that god almighty is the one
who's created heavens in the earth
here is the one that's merciful very
merciful this is something that you hear
in the Quran Allah every chapter starts
with this except one
bismillah r-rahman r-rahim god almighty
in the name of God the most merciful the
very merciful so what's good why is God
keep repeating that the most merciful
the very mercy with the Gumbo's why
because he's trying to show you that he
is the most merciful he wants the best
for you so what is saying he is the
owner of the day of judgment and then
what do we say in our prayer you alone
we worship and you are no we ask for
help
this here is the problem with and lots
of other religions they go through Jesus
Christians believe Jesus is good we say
how could God be a man you know that's
what we say yeah this is going to
realize ok but this is why ok can God
become a wood